Schau!
Moin Leute, ja Stream bisschen außer der Reihe, ich hab gedacht wenn wir jetzt schon den restlichen
Tag Warzone spielen, mache ich einfach mal den Stream an. Ich weiß, dass nicht so viele Leute am
Start sind, die Warzone gucken wollen, aber ich denke mal, wenn ich jeden ganzen Tag da bin, warum nicht?
Je nachdem wie lange wir spielen, machen wir nachher vielleicht noch sowas, ansonsten, ansonsten nicht.
Mal gucken. Wer ist denn schon da, der Kelmore ist am Start, GameShock auch da, huge. Meine Tastatur-Settings sind kaputt.
So, wir haben jetzt mal TeamSpeaker im Puten. Leute, ihr glaubt nicht, wir sind im TeamSpeaker,
also ich hab Stream an, nur zur Info. Jetzt können wir uns nicht mehr erlauben, hier Scheiße zu bauen.
Na komm, wir haben heute, wir haben heute zwei, drei, wie viele Games haben wir gespielt?
Drei Games und eins gewonnen. Ja und Vormittag haben wir auch noch zwei gespielt, komm lass uns mal mitzählen.
33% Wind-Rate, easy. Vollzeit-Streamsor sagt der Chat, nee nicht wirklich. Wie spricht man
diese Map eigentlich aus? Verdansk? Ist das niederländisch? Oh, huge.
Mehr russischer Akzent bitte, ah, muss man das russisch aussprechen? Verdansk, ja.
Ich kann auf russisch bloß, Privet. Ja, wir müssen jetzt was killen.
Easy, easy wins, also hier. Was, wen kann ich muten? Achso, ja das stimmt.
Das, generell ist die Sound-Up-Mischung in dem Spiel merkwürdig. Welchen? Nee, wir gehen,
wir gehen lieber an, ja doch, Stalgetown, blau, voll, volle Pulle, ja klar. Wow, slacked,
alles slacked krass. Klassisches TDM gibt's, ja. Das ist quasi
ein klassisches TDM. Poggers. Was zum Geist ist das für ne Kacke? Achtung, Achtung, Achtung,
auf dem Dach vielleicht? Was? Woa, woa, woa, woa, ich werde schon angeschneibert.
Hier kommt bei mir gleich was rein, Achtung. Oh, das Fenster, shit, shit, shit, shit. Alter,
das ist jetzt wirklich TDM, einer bei mir, ich leg, perfekt, das ist wirklich TDM, Alter.
Komm jetzt, easy. So, ich hoffe ich komm gleich wieder.
Das war echt TDM. Wir haben nur Kackwaffe gehabt.
So, ich bin wieder da. Audi ist nice, ich brauch irgendwas. P90 ist top, P90, wie der ist,
egal, 60, komm, besser. Irgendwas, 46 Schuss. Ah, M4, exzellent. Sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr
gut. Gut, da sind wir jetzt ja ganz gut ausgerüstet,
wir können losgehen. Nee, passt schon. Was? Verwirrt. Dankeschön, easykiller. Haben wir
noch Platten irgendwo? So, mal gucken, was der empfiehlt. Ein Team,
ich hab sie gleich. Schwimmbad, Schwimmbad, Schwimmbad, auf dem Dach von links irgendwo,
ich hab's nicht genau gesehen. Irgendwo hinter euch. Der kommt jetzt.
Auf dem Dach, beide auf dem Dach. Oh, KS, ich hab fast, ich hab halt nix mehr.
Einer down, Dach, Dach, Dach, Dach. Ich hör aber noch Leute, ich hör noch Leute
hier. MonkaW. Danke. Ah, die haben Money. Aber ansonsten haben sie nicht so viel, muss
man sagen. Aber wir haben ordentlich Money jetzt, passt. Wir haben auch noch nicht genug
Geld, wir müssen hier mal. Ja, ich auch. Genau, genau, das hier mal weg.
Sag mal, Chet, kann das sein, dass der Stream rockelt?
Wir können direkt hochgehen. Echt, Money, Money. Kein Rockeln. Ah, die Bitrate ist glaube
ich einfach zu gering. Ich stelle gleich mal die Bitrate hoch. Warte mal. Kann mal kurz
einer halbe Minute, katsch, halbe Minute, zehn Sekunden aufpassen, dass ich die Bitrate
hochstellen kann. Geht schnell. Output 7,9. Exzellent. Passt. So, jetzt sollte es besser
aussehen. Ja, ich hole mir auch noch eine Runde Platten. Und dann holen wir uns eine
Runde Drops. Wir können weiter drinnen, wir können hier drinnen weiter looten.
Du meinst diese Squad-Streaming-Geschichte? Ja, das ist cool.
Aber es geht nur ab Partner, sonst musst du halt über Multivit machen. Hier sind noch
Platten. What? Beste Sniper. Ja, ja, ja.
Krasser Unterschied, ey. Nur 108 Frames jetzt, wenn OBS läuft. Ja, ich auch, ich auch so
in dem Dreh. Na, jetzt geht es wieder 160, aber trotzdem. Vielleicht soll ich es doch
mal über GPU-Encoding machen. Ist hier irgendwo was? Ja, ja. Nimm alles, was ich habe. Ich
habe ja nicht viel. Hier ist nichts. Was ist hier los? Haben die alle schon weggelootet?
Äh, exzellent. So muss das sein. Das ist voll ungewohnt, wenn man 40 FPS weniger hat
als sonst. Es kommt einem fast vor, als sind 120 FPS schon gleich ruckeln. Das ist das
bestoptimierte Spiel. Es geht quasi gar nicht besser. Ach, darum geht es. Ah, verstehe.
Also quasi umso größer das Spiel, umso besser. Nee, nee, der Euro Truck Simulator ist das
noch, mit irgendwie 3000 Euro DLC. Ja, aber ich glaube, dass der neue Flight Simulator
echt 80 Terabyte oder so, das hat er nicht. Nur bei Online, oder wie war das? Wenn du
das neue Terrain mit den Bäumen spielen willst und so, dann. Also ich sehe nichts. Es kämmt
alles nur rum, ist nichts da. Ich komme mal runtergehüpft zu dir. Ruhi. Passt hoch zum
Samen fahren, komm. Wollen wir echt da hoch fahren? Ja, hoch kämpfen dauert bisschen
unendlich lang, finde ich. Chat sagt, ihr seid zu leise. Ich stelle euch mal ein bisschen
lauter nach der Runde. Das macht dich nicht lauter aus, dass du übersteuerst wie Sau.
Das macht dich nicht lauter aus, ich habe null. Der Chat fragt, ob wir den unendlich Munitions-Bug
kennen. Kennen wir den? Nein, kennen wir nicht. Ich kenne ihn auch nicht. Ich hätte auch
keine Schmerzen mit gerade, ja. Nee, kenne ich nicht. Kenn ich nicht. Irgendwie. Ja,
das ist ein bisschen auffällig. Irgendwie. Ich kann aber auch mit dem Auto hoch aus dem
Berg und dann von da oben mal fängen. Boah, ich sehe die schon da oben. Boah, in der Mitte
glaube ich. Wir haben noch ein bisschen Munition geholt. Sag mal, kann das sein, dass wir außer
am Anfang, wo TDM war, keine Gegner gesehen haben? Nee, keine Gegner. Aber wir sind noch
alles dort gestern gegangen. Aber ich weiß gar nicht, wo die alle hin sind. Es leben
noch 50 Leute. Ich habe so Angst, durch diesen Tunnel zu laufen. Nee, nee, da wird nichts
sein. Wenn hier auch nur eine rein guckt, da oben, das war es. Wir können noch besser
schießen. High Octane Gameplay Chat, ne? Ja, das ist halt unglückbar. Ich weiß nicht,
wo die Gegner sind. Was ist? Wollen wir da hoch? Was? Perfekt. Echt jetzt? Ja. Du musst
auf die Telefonzelle springen und dann auf diese Schlinge. Diese Telefonzelle mit den
Schwingen und Fliegen und alles. Ach, das sehe ich. Ach, genau. Oh Gott, das ist ja perfekt.
Ja, lass uns noch mal einen Haufen. Ja, so. Ich sehe schon gleich, wer hier umgesniped
oder irgendwas. Oh, ich sage bloß, da gibt es Gegner. Exzellent. Wir haben auch kein
Geld. Also so ein paar UAVs und so wären schon nicht schlecht, bevor wir da reingehen.
Aber hier ist gelotet. Aber mach mal so ein Popgeld. Wobei, die sind ja UAVs. Aber hier
oben ist noch eine Kiste. Nee, das ist auch schon unten. Wo sind denn die? Ich sehe niemand.
Ich glaube, die sind da hinten, so bei Rosh. Wir haben die Anti-Stream-Sniper, die rennen
weg. Die rennen weg. Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal. Warte mal, was? Nee. Wo sind die
denn? Kann doch nicht sein, dass wir ein Drittel von der Map... Ja, wo sind die alle?
Dieses Haus hier und sowas, da könnten vielleicht welche schimmeln, wenn die richtig campen.
Echt hart, also... Man kommt auch von unten wieder runter. Also, so wenig Gegner habe
ich hier selten gesehen. Also hier sind Scheiben kaputt an den Fenstern. Hier war auf jeden
Fall schon was. Nee, hier ist auch nichts mehr. Ah, hier ist einer bei mir im Haus, bei mir
im Haus. Unten, unten, unten. Hier in der Ecke war er. Excellent, kommt mal zurück.
Oh, von hinten auch. Fuck. Perfekt. Excellent. Na toll. Ah, fuck, Alter. Ey, so ein Rumgesitze
wieder. Aber das war halt auch wieder richtig unnötig von denen. Oh man. Huge, genau. Jetzt
gibt es Huge Gulag-Win. Und dann... Oh, da war einfach niemand im Gulag. Ich mache euch
mal einen Ticken lauter. Ah. Der Drop kommt so lange nicht. Ja, was willst du, was kannst
du jetzt großartig machen? Es gibt gerade gar nichts zu tun. Es gibt nicht mehr einen
Drop, wo man richtig hin kann. Mach die weg, die uns geholt haben. Alter, was hocken die
denn da schon wieder den ganzen Tag rum? Wir waren da das ganze Spiel schon. Oh Gott. Die
haben sich nicht bewegt, glaube ich. Die hatten, die hatten, der eine hat eine Standard-MPP
gehabt, also ich glaube sogar der andere. Nee, der hatte so eine richtig schlechte Klassen-MPP.
Es gibt ja noch nicht mal einen Drop hier, ich sehe nichts. Da gibt es echt nichts. Da
wäre noch ein Sicherungsauftrag, aber... Ja, mach den Kopfgeldauftrag, easy. Towers
sind, äh, enemies. Jetzt haben sie natürlich gutes Equipment. Ja, nimm die Hobbs oder so,
ich habe keine Ahnung. Ja, komm. Jetzt hat da auch noch jemand drin versucht. Der hat
die Kiste nicht mal aufgemacht, das sind so Königskämpfer. Die Kisten zulassen. Hä,
wie krass das vercampt ist gerade, was geht da ab? Die sind aber schlecht. Ich höre
sie, ich höre sie rumrennen. Ich auch, bringt halt nichts, wenn ich da weiter laufe, dann
sehen die mich aus dem Fenster, wenn ich da weiter laufe. Das ist so maximal gut gemacht
von denen. Das ist maximal ehrenhaft. Kisten zulassen, um zu baiten, das ist so krank.
5.000 IQ. Die holen auch noch ihren Maid. Wo ist der? Da kommt er. Der hat mich nicht
gesehen. Ne, der guckt doch überhaupt nicht. Der Sprayhawk. Hammer. Das hast du gebraucht.
Neostyle. Also, die haben wirklich die ganze Runde nichts anderes gemacht, nichts anderes
als da gesessen. Heftig. Also, so eine Runde hatten wir lange nicht. Am Anfang TDM, dann
nichts und dann am Arsch der Welt rumgecampt, Alter. Hugo V., Dankeschön für den Prime
Sub. Wer ist neu hier? Real Nikolai, Moin. Was haben wir sonst noch? Easykiller, auch
wieder 8 Monate am Start. Das Audio ist nicht nur merkwürdig, sondern crap. Das Modern Warfare
Audio ist echt Hardcore Fail. Richtig feels Batman. Aber egal, nächste Runde. Ja, du hast
schon recht, aber wir hatten ja auch nichts an Killstreaks oder sonst was. Ganz ohne
Erwiesnis zu gewinnen und Zeug ist halt auch nicht so das Ding. Es war aber eine sehr merkwürdige
Runde. F muss man noch pressen, das ist doch das neue Meter. Jetzt werden sie jetzt wieder
mehr lädt. Nachkampft. Wo ist er hin? Wow. Hey, hey. Ich will hier nachkampfen. 76 Grad.
So, wir können uns jetzt ja schon mal überlegen. Das fliegt ziemlich gut, also wenn das wirklich
genauso über die Mitte. Ja, ist auch. Die ganzen World Record High-Skill-Games gehen
ja alle eins nebendran. Ich pass nach der Runde den Sound ein bisschen an. Es ist nicht
so einfach, weil das Game sonst zu laut wird, wenn ich das insgesamt lauter mache. Ja, ja,
habe ich schon. Habe ich schon auf 14. Das ist, ja, das ist ein bisschen Fail. Ich könnte
in Game das Game lauter machen, insgesamt lauter. Das muss ich nach der Runde mal gucken.
Aber im Flugzeug jetzt ist eh unnormal laut. Da sehen ja die Geier schon wieder hier beim
Fallschirm springen am Start. Okay. Vor dir ist einer. Okay, okay, ich komm. Ich habe
eine M4, ich habe eine M4. Vorne ist einer. Ein Gelb. Schwimm mal, schwimm mal zwei Stück.
Ja, ja, ich gehe auch auf die andere Seite rauf. Oben auf dem Schwimmbad, auf dem Schwimmbad
hat oben einer. Wow, oh, oh, fuck. Ich bin, ey, hier ist wieder TDM angesagt. Ich muss
hier auch mal weg, wir brauchen ein paar Platten. Was haben wir hier? Ich habe nicht mal viel
Muni. Jetzt kommt die Shotgun raus und die werden uns gehauen. Die sind hier, die sind
hier im Haus drin. Ich bin hier hinter dir, Juli. Nein, fuck, Alter. Hätte klappen können.
Es ist nur noch einer gewesen, nur noch einer gewesen. Da wo ich gestorben bin, in dem grünen
Schild. Wir sind hier richtig reingerusht. Was zum Geier, wo ist der? Will der mich verarschen?
So, easy win. Ich bin gleich wieder da. Es ist da einer, ein Gelb bei euch. Okay, vielleicht
ist es der, der gestorben ist. Von da hat es gerade geschossen zumindest. P90. Ja, das
die, die hatte ich eben. Die hatte ich eben, um die zu killen, glaube ich. Dann lass hier
mal weg oder haben wir genug zum kaufen? Ja, aber erst mal überleben. Dann lass mal wieder
in Richtung Flughafen. Ja, lass die oben haben Geld gesammelt für uns. Ah, Muni, Muni, Muni.
Ich sehe nichts. Über dem Zeitlager. Bei mir, über mir. Nee. Was, what, was zum, ich
glaube es nicht. Ich glaube es nicht, Alter. Was zum Teufel. Alter, Kacke. Ich habe voll
vorbeigeknallt. Ah, shit. Huge NA. Oh, das war verkackt, Alter. In die Richtung. Direkt
da, ich kann nichts machen, ich kann den nicht ansagen. Ich, ich geh hier rein, wenn du willst.
Ich geh hier rein, ich hab ein Schild. Ich kann dich decken. Komm rein zu mir. Er brennt.
Er brennt. Ist er noch einer? Eist, danke. Nee, echt nicht. Are you not interested in
me? Nee, echt nicht. Hier liegt er noch. Wow, wow, wow, wow, Alter. Ich brauch irgendwas
mit Range. Ja, weg hier. Was ist das eigentlich für ne Crab Waffe hier? Ist ne Auke. Auke
ist richtig gut. Find ich, aber. Ist da oben einer? Nee. Ich glaub, da oben sind Gegner
drauf. Wir können auch die Kaufstation, ah, wir haben kein Geld. Wir müssten eigentlich
auch mal looten gehen am Bahn, äh, ich wollt grad sagen am Bahnhof, am Flughafen. Max,
hier. Noch einer, aber egal. Kiste, Kiste. Wo, wo, wo. Die kommen aus dem Airfordraub.
Von wo? Von links oder? Hier. Einer down. Ich geh mal mit Schild, ich kann mit Schild reingucken.
Unten. Unten auf dem Weg ist einer. Ein Gelb auf dem Weg war einer. Gelb auf dem Weg.
Unten, unten, unten. Es kann durchaus sein, dass ihr hier unten gleich reingestellt kommt.
Ich kann mit Schild reingehen und gucken. Geht nicht. Wir haben, wir haben genug Geld für
den Drop, wir können auch, ah, haben wir nicht. 300 fehlen. Ja, dann looten wir hier mal durch.
Das ist aber noch, gell. Irgendwo ist hier einer, ja. Müssen wir uns ein bisschen aufpassen.
Kommt ein Auto. Ach nee, hier gehts ja gar nicht lang. Also wie gesagt, der eine ist,
auf jeden Fall noch irgendwo hinter uns. Ja. Ok, erstmal Loot. Die, die mit ihrem Auto
da gekommen sind, die hatten auch irgendeine Mission. Wir könnten uns das auch direkt schon
mal hoch richten und dann hin tun, weil da kommen die jetzt diesmal eh. Uns fehlen noch
ein Geldplatz zum Drop. Nee, wir sind ja ganz gut ausgestattet. Das stimmt eigentlich auch
wieder. Das passt schon. Wir sollten jetzt lieber vielleicht noch ein erster in die Revue
oder irgendwas holen. Oder ein Zellfress, irgendwas. Platten und so. Ja, Platten können
wir auch noch brauchen. Hier noch kurz looten, wenn da keiner ist. Ich hoffe mal, dass hier
nicht hoch da. Wir können hier auch in dieses Haus hier gehen, wo ich bin. Nochmal Geld.
Ich hab halt nur AR dabei, ne? Brauchst du Sniper Muni? Achso. Die sind in ihrem Drop.
Das sind die mit den Autos. Die müssten eigentlich gleich crossen. Guck mal rechts von uns, da
war auch irgendwas. Ich guck mal, ob hinten irgendwas anrückt. Ihr macht das schon. Die
schießen glaube ich auf den, der sich da von uns versteckt hat, so ein bisschen. Alter,
Leute, guckt euch mal den Flughafen an, ey. Huge Detail. So, ich leg mich jetzt mal hin.
Ich kann von oben eh nix machen. Hier an der Kaufe ist jemand neben uns, die ich markiert
hab. Hier hockt es bestimmt wieder drin, ich sag's euch. Gleich kommt ein RPG oder irgendwas.
Ist das die Kaufe, die ich gerade markiert hab? Jaja, da war auf jeden Fall was. Alter,
ich bin gleich da. Okay, wer hat noch Platten übrig? Kannst du mir was troppen? Die haben
mich richtig hart getroffen. Besser als nix. Alter, was zum Geier. What the fuck, wie funktioniert
das? Excellent. Und dann? Monkeys, was ist das? Wie soll das funktionieren? Jaja, ist mir
schon klar. Ah, okay. Okay, verstanden. Siehst du was? Links, links, Achtung. An Gelb.
Der eine probiert hier irgendwie hoch zu kommen, ne? Der ist dann Richtung hier gelaufen. Müssen
wir ein bisschen abchecken, nicht dass er es schafft. Er schafft es nicht, er kann nicht
so hoch. Da ist noch ein Gegner, blau und rot. Äh, klar ist das nicht. Das ist jetzt schlecht,
die können jetzt voll reinballern hier. Excellent Strats. Na gut, die müssen auf jeden Fall jetzt
zu uns. Ich habe einen gedown von denen, bei dem Verkehrsschipper. Okay. Ja, rechts irgendwo
ist er. Der versucht glaube ich hoch zu kommen, ne? Ist genau hier. Ja, wir müssen gucken,
da sind ja bestimmt noch mehr. Hast du ihn? Nice. Oh, von unten schießt noch was hoch.
Ja, ich kann ein bisschen was trocken. Ja, ich habe MP5. Alles game ruckelt voll, wenn
es an ist, was ist das für ein Crap? Ja, ich habe ja noch nicht, aber gerade Warzone ruckelt.
Normaler MP geht. Also, die anderen drei, die uns da hinten angegriffen haben, die sind
ja auch noch da, ne? Also, die sind da nicht irgendwie weg. Von unten kamen gerade Schüsse,
ja? Es kann durchaus sein, dass die mittlerweile unten sind. Du kommst eigentlich nur über
einen Sneaky weg. Ja, du kommst nur über das Ding da hoch, aber lass mal kurz den Tunnel
noch abcampen mit der Zone, vielleicht ran die rein. Ach, du meinst, dass die über die
Tunnel ruckeln und die Zone kommt gerade. So, wie sieht es denn hier aus? Ich sehe mal
nichts, ne? Ne. Wenn du hast, ja. Doch, doch, ist nicht verkehrt. An blau ist einer, unten
an der Kaufe ist einer, und dann grün einer, ja. Wollen wir mit, komm, soll ich mit dem
LKW machen, komm. Ich sehe nichts. Ach, da. What the hell? Was machen die da? Was machen
die da? Hallo? Hallo? Er holt ihn hoch, er holt ihn hoch. Oh, ich, ja. Ich hab was richtig
Dummes gemacht, aber ich find's geil. Ich geh jetzt hier oben aufs Dach und baller da runter.
Habt ihr ungefähr eine Ahnung, wo genau sie sind? Warum? Ja, weil die mich einfach auf
schießen. Wo denn, wo denn hast, kannst du die mal? Unter dir, am Stein. Aber blau
was? Ne. Team vibed. Ja, schöner Beat. Oh man, ey. Oh man, ey. Oh man, ey. Oh man,
ey. Oh man, ey. Ich kann nichts machen, ey. Hatte irgendwas Sinnvolles dabei? Ja, eine
Grau, ich will. Hab ich selbst. Na lass mal hier weg. Äh, lass mal in die Zone laufen.
Willst du nicht das Auto mitnehmen? Nein, das sehen alle. Also der, ne, die war das.
Nee, das war ich nicht. Call of Duty Steine kamen in die hoch bestimmt nicht, oder? Da
Da kommst du nicht hoch
Wir müssen so vorn rumlaufen
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an Battlefield 3 mit dem rumgestellts hier über die Steine
Auch nicht richtig funktioniert
Da kommst du auch nicht hoch
Oben ist out of map, was bist du da oben
Hoch
Null
Die Zone ist sehr gut für uns aber
Bist du dir sicher, dass sie im Haus sind
Da waren vorher die rote Punkte
Ich guck mal
Hardspeed
Nix da
Das heißt echt nichts
Kommt man hier hoch
Call of Duty Steine
Wir müssen mit in die Zone hinten rum
Dann schaffen wir es vielleicht
Hier hatten wir absolut keine Deckung
Das heißt wir müssen uns hier die Deckung holen
Hier hat es gute Steine
Ja
Hier kommt mit nichts vorbei
Unten schießt einer am Boden
Also falls die echt noch in dem Haus drin sind
Müssen wir gucken von hinten
Hier sind wir in der Zone drin mit blau
Gut wir können aber jetzt noch kurz gucken
Oh da schießt einer was
Da sind nur noch 18 Gegner
Ein so krasses rumgecampe ist da wahnsinnig gerade
Wann denn?
Die anderen Spiele waren nicht so krass
Ja das geht schon klar
Das ist echt nicht normal
Ins unten schießt
Noch weiter
Ich hab es noch ganz ganz leise gehört
Ja irgendwo
Die Zone kommt so langsam
Wir sind in der Zone rein
Wir sind einmal unter uns da
Ich geh mal zu Max
Ich komm auch hinter falls irgendwas von hinten reingelaufen kommt
Ich hör nicht dass sich einer zwischen euch rein macht
Ja
Ne von da kann nichts mehr kommen
Wir haben hier eine richtig gute Kurzposition
Um zu gucken wo die Gegner sind
Aber auch nicht
Hier hoch müssen wir vielleicht
Lass erst mal gucken wo noch was kommt
Ich krieg
Da hoch
Zone komm her
Komm her Zone
Holy hell
Wir haben den
High Ground noch
Lass mal hier oben
Wir müssen so rum reingehen
Dann haben wir eigentlich von hinten nichts mehr zu befürchten
Aber ihr lauft genau auf dieses eine
Wenn ihr rechts umgeht seid ihr lost
Ihr könnt nichts machen wenn ihr rechts umgeht
Ja ich will nur schieferieren
Die Zone drückt euch in ein Haus rein
Hier ist ein Gegner
Ja ich seh ich seh ich weiß
What the hell
Sterben
Random keine Ahnung wie schnell er mich umgekillt
Und umgenietet hat
WTF
Ist das Stream leise
Echt Leute ist das Stream leise
Der Gegner hat mich einfach komplett
Weggestellt
Ah die Leute sind leise
Ja ok das
Dann stell ich jetzt mal kurz Sound ein
Wie macht man das jetzt am besten
Target right here
Nein
Aber wie schnell der Typ mich eben weggestellt
Aber wie
Es war echt krass
Wie schnell er mich eben weggestellt hat der Typ
Hättest du vom ersten angefangen
Mit Grau rausschießen
Hättest du gegangen
Ich weiss
So ich muss mal kurz
So machen wir mal das Game
Ein bisschen leiser
Erst ein bisschen lauter
Gucken ob das besser
Funktioniert jetzt
Ich hab den rechts nicht erwartet
Und Loco
Ich glaub jetzt ist besser
Hoff ich mal
Klar carryn lassen was sonst
Erst ein Teamspiel
Jetzt ist es wieder warm alter
Los
Und sonst so
Also Sound Settings
Sind wirklich ziemlich
Kacke einzustellen
Weil ihr seid
Jetzt viel zu laut
Dann machen wir jetzt hier lauter
So ist besser und das Game wird
Leiser gemacht
So machen wir das
Jetzt muss es besser funktionieren
So ich glaub Leute chat
Ich glaub jetzt ist die Lautstärke besser
Flamehaze was meinste
Spielern
Nee nicht so wirklich
Ich spiel ja gar nicht so oft
Aber ich muss sagen
Es macht doch mehr Bock als ich gedacht hätte
Im Garten
Das ist ein Fischteich
Aber ich hab mich zu sehr drauf verlassen
Dass ihr da mit kommt
Oder dass ihr da früher da seid
Weil ich über Openfield den
Ich dachte es reicht bis du den Feltens
Du machst was dummes da musst du sagen
Wo wir hin müssen
Nee es war ja schon absichtlich dumm
Ich wusste ja dass es dumm war
Aber es war halt 50-50 Gamble ob es reicht
Darüber zu crossen bis er den Openfield
Aber es hat halt auf 2 Meter nicht gereicht
So jetzt hoffe ich dass die Sound Settings passen
Let's go schreib ich in dein Chat
Und dann komm ich wieder zu
Teamspeak 3
Ja klar
4 gab es nie
Alter Leute reißt euch mal zusammen
Wir können auch woanders hin
Das ist wurscht
Stalzstown
Das ist diesmal ziemlich am Arsch der Welt
Teamspeak 5 ist dieser Discord Klon
Der irgendwie
Keiner Abnehmer finden wird glaube ich
Der sollte doch schon rauskommen vor einem Jahr oder so
Die Betas
Closed Beta glaube ich
Closed Beta für einen
Voice Chat
Ich vertau dir was mit dem los ist
Es lag bei mir oh mein Gott
Ja ich clean
Wollte ich nicht beschweren
Ich hab nur ein 27 erbringt der Service
Ich hab meine Hand komplett entdeckt
Ich höre euch irgendwie doppelt krall
Ah
Hier ist nix
Nix gelandet glaube ich
Hoho
Shop in the UAV am Start
Ja wir kriegen bestimmt gleich 400
Was kriegen wir denn dafür
Wenn der im Superstar gleich down geht
Ich glaub das ist so ein Viertel eher oder
Jetzt ist das Game viel zu leise
Viel zu leise
Kann man das Game bisschen lauter stellen
Ja
Ok Money Money
Plates perfekt
Wir können doch fast kaufen
Jawoll
Vierer kann man so viel schneller kaufen
Ist so gut
Ok das Game meins gut mir heute mit Loot
Was ich aber nicht verstehe ist
Wenn du genau so viel Geld brauchst
Aber die schrauben da die wahrscheinlich
Aber bei Solo brauchst du auch 10
Aber die haben doch da die Drop
Die haben hochgeschraubt dass du mehr Geld
Getroppt bekommst
Das wäre klug das hätten die doch sicherlich nicht gemacht
Bei Solo hast du
Junge voll der Haken
Das ist ein trauriges Spiel
Ach verdient
Bei Solo hast du aus 3 Kisten oder 4 Kisten
Das ist fast wie bei Plunder
Mein ganzes Geld liegt an Kisten
Ok ich nehme
Wie viel hattest du?
Ich kann dir was geben oder habt ihr genug für einen Drop?
Reicht schon
Also zu zweit nicht
Ich brauch 3,7 bitte
Ich bin ja richtig laut
Reicht nicht hier jetzt
Danke ich nehme ich komm da raus
Da wird immer nur abgezählt
Aber es sind Zeiten der Rezession halt auch verständlich
Rezession
Jawoll
Ah Platten
Poggers
Poggers Platte
Aber Platte
Der wusste schon als das Spiel rausfasste
Predicted
Ok wo ist doch unser Bounty Target
Oh Super Store
Ach so
Ja das reicht nicht
Oder ich halte einen richtig krassen Shot
Alles vorbei
Ich fliege auch hinterher jetzt
Volle Pulle
Also wir haben
8 Sekunden
Easy
Haha
Das Ding ist wirklich hier als Cockpit und die uns
Ja man der war total ausnutzt
Und deswegen haben wir den hier auch verzweckt
Oben drauf sniped einer 8
Aus dem Fenster
Hinter uns kommen Teams
Achtung Achtung Achtung
Ich glaube oben im Fenster im Haus war glaube einer
Exlet habt ihr getroffen?
C4
Hit Hit Hit
Was zum Teufel von wo?
Von wo? Vom Dach?
Ich seh nix
Ich seh Super Store auch nix
Ok
Ok ich geh mal raus
Ich seh ihn ja
Hat gut Hit
Ist hinter dem Felsen
Nein
What the hell
Das ist wieder weg
Ja ja
Ich seh den gar nicht irgendwo am Felsen
Hier kommt einer
Ja
Einer ausgenockt hier hinten
Einer ist tot
Ja ja ich hol dich ich hol dich
Aber ich brauch unbedingt Platten
Vorne vorne vorne vorm Haus
Kaffee Kaffee
Ah fuck im Haus
Im Haus da wo wir eben waren
Es könnte sein dass einer mich pusht
Er pusht mich er pusht mich unten
Ja ich dachte das sind die
Aus deutsch Torn sind die nächsten schon wieder heiß auf uns
Aus deutsch Torn ich seh ihn
Ja doch da hier
Junge das ist ja ein
Das andere Bild gerade
Lass mal jetzt zum Airport gehen
Lass das ohne Witz nicht gehen
Ihr könnt mich vielleicht
Vielleicht könnt ihr mich retzen klar
Dann haut ab dann haut lieber ab
Ja lass weg ohne Witz
Ja vor dem Haus
Ok ich hab Gulag überlebt pass pass pass
Wo seid ihr alle
Ihr seid ziemlich gesplittert
Sind die jetzt eigentlich tot bei euch
Am Store oder wo wir eben
Was zum Teufel
Ich weiß gar nicht wo ich hin soll
Bring mir mal was mit
Seine Mates kommen nicht
Ja natürlich kommen die
Ah guck mal hier kommt ein Trop
Packst du dich über mich
Ja
Ich guck ob es irgendwo was gibt
Einer genug von dir du kannst kochen
Ich will das nicht pushen
Lass sie holen
Ist nix
Hier gibt es null
Wir sollten erstmal unseren Leuten helfen
Ok
Jetzt auch noch ne scheiß Shotgunne
Egal
Lass jetzt mal hin
Unsere Leute irgendwie wenn es geht
Seid ihr auf dem Dach
Warte
Kommt man hier überhaupt hochgescheit
So ne
Ach hier
Der ist oben drauf anscheinend
Oben links
Wo war denn der Dude
Ich war schon mit dem Trop
44 Meter rechts
Unten
Ja ja ja
Leiter Leiter Leiter
100%
Ich komm von hinter euch hoch
Ich hab euch
Die 29 Meter unter uns
Hinten und schießt noch
Hinten
34 Meter rechts
Hinten sind die
Gucken wir euch da oben
Ach hier gehts gar nicht rein
Du musst da gleich eh raus
Ich komm mit
Nee komm doch vor
Da kommen gleich so viele
Da bist du hopeless
Los komm her
Kein guter Fight
12.000
Du bist zu wert
Lass erst mal safe gehen
Lass ja kurz reingehen
Ach da kann man mal wieder nicht durch springen
Ich hab die mega aufgehalten dadurch
Ich brauch noch irgendeine halbwegs hin
Volle Waffe
Ja ja ich komm gleich runter vom Dach drauf köpft
Lass erst mal jetzt bitte von hier oben noch mal gucken
Nicht dass die alle zu gut kommen
Da kommen einige glaube ich
Ja ich stell mal ein C-Torrent oben hin
Auf Yolo Basis
Ja das war's
Das war's
Ja
Hier ist es glaube ich besser
Wie kommt man denn hier hoch eigentlich
Ich komm jetzt nach rechts von der Straße
Okay hab's
Wer war der falsche?
Ich bin's nicht
Da sind sie
Dahinten ich sehs
Da hier
Einer gedauert im Bus
Perfekt
Ich seh Fernrohre
Ich hab noch nie dieses Shield-Currents genutzt
Aber das ist ein gutes Endkontroll
Boah
Alter die
Die moveen die moveen die moveen
Mein Gott
Einer Shield Break
Hinterm Heuballen
Hinter Gelb ist einer
Die sind auf dem roten Dach wo wir vorhin drauf waren
Ja
Hits ohne Ende haben die
Max?
Die sind auf dem Dach wo der Ping ist
Beide snipen
Der rechts war noch Max
Da hinten ist er drin
Ich hab keine Muni mehr
Ja
Ich komm mit
Ich hab aber noch hier
Ich hab noch 13k
Die müssen da noch sein
Ja aber die anderen sind jetzt hier
Egal ich probier's
Lass mal oben noch nen Dropkauf
Hier sind Gegner
Oh mein Gott die sind da bei mir
Egal
Das waren die gleichen
44 Meter geradeaus zwei Leute
38 sind oben drauf
Rechts rum ja
Oben
Oben ha?
Hier machen wir Totenschild an und haben mal links ab
Ich geh hier oben
Oben drauf ist schon eine Kaufnutzung
Die werden jetzt kaufen
Max ich komm
Ich komm
Wo ist der?
Links
Dahinter ist eine 1AP gewesen
Wieder ausgenockt
E drauf
Alter
Weg gesniped
Nice
Sehr gut perfekt
Einfach in your face gesniped
Echt gesniped
Wir sind am Arsch der Welt gesworn
Aha
Okay wenigstens irgendwas
Ich find das ne Drohne
Wir können eigentlich das Geld zusammenlegen
Dann brauchen wir nur noch 5k oder so
Ich glaub wir können crossen
Was hast du gekauft?
Helft jetzt
Wir brauchen das WC Drop für die
Wir brauchen das WC Drop
Wenn wir die Suche machen haben wir eh genug
Was denn?
Rechts von euch sind Gegner
Wie wir immer wieder zum Damm hochkommen
Bei Blaus sind Gegner
Die werden aber beschossen von weiter hinten
Okay
Ich weiß nicht ob das so gut ist weil wir hier mitten auf dem Feld
Die crossen
Ich kann von hier oben
Was ist das denn für Ansicht?
Die müssen selber crossen
Die müssen jetzt auch rennen
Hier kämpfts garantiert wieder
In den Häusern irgendwo
Bisschen nackig
Ich bin reich aber immer noch useless
Wir haben noch Geld
Wir haben noch Geld immer
Money Money
Lass mal in die Zone in so ein Haus rein gehen und dann
Guck dir ab
Monka Zone
Hier von rechts kommen
Okay hier sind noch Kästen drin
Wir kommen hier hoch
Wo?
Da oben
Aber in 36 Sekunden push die Zone
Hinter mir
Links oben
Da unten
Ich seh den
Wo lag denn der?
Das war nicht mein kill
Ich hab ihn gedauert
Die wissen jetzt aber das wir kommen
Was ist das für ne richtige Keilpanzer?
Noch mal
Oben sind die Sniper
Das hier weg
Wo sind die?
Ich hab ihn gedauert
Scheiße
Da ist ein Pocketsch
Genau
so
wo kommt denn hier was
da killen wir alle
wir können auch über wie es kaufen wenn wir eine geld gibt
kann man vorbeilaufen
ja das ist übelst das ist das ist wirklich big brain big brain
ja ich habe den uav soll man den schon ausmachen noch warten
ich habe nichts habe kein load out von links kommt gleich noch einer
auf der kaufstation
ja wir haben gesucht den typ haben wir gesucht hier ist ein tropf
vorhin liegt auch noch ein tropf aber ich weiß nicht ob wir da raus können
naja ich könnte könnte ihn gebrauchen aber muss nicht unbedingt sein
ok ich gucke jetzt ich hole mir schnell um ein drop und dann zum glück habe ich da keiner
gewischt
so viel wahl mehr glaube ich ja wir sind hier safe wenn wir hier
ohne die fahr von links und rechts und wir waren gegner uns aber nicht sicher
wir sind hier aber drin nur von der antenne können wir uns von oben holen
hier oben ist auch noch einer
wer ist hinter der barriere da hinter dem
hier ist einer bei mir bei mir gegenüber vor mir einer dauernd hier bei mir gegenüber
ich war übelst josef die runde oder
park ich sag doch chat only wins easy wins vor allem
ich habe kein win counter
keck wehlul hd kannst das komm mal verschieben um zwei stellen aber bei mir ist ja auch nicht
viel ich hause dich danach dann oder mal gucken wir spielen noch eine weile
ja er war50
im sinnlos von rechterm wann fange
Ich sag doch nur easy wins heute. Es ist so anstrengend das game teilweise
Manchmal gar nicht es ist irgendwie merkwürdig manchmal hast du
zehn runden am stück
Da gehts übels ab und und du denkst du so ja easy kein problem und manchmal hast du runden die sind übel stressig
So habe ich irgendwas übersehen im chat kurz hochgucken
Tänzer ja wenn du sachen freispielen willst es schippt man das Beste
Spielen will es ist schippt man das Beste. Kann man was gucken
Ne passt
Der rauch der explosion nutzt um sich zu repositionieren das war eher glück
Ich habe gedacht er pusht ich weiß man c4 vor aber wenn rauch da ist dann nichts wie weg
Weil ich hatte keinen schimmer mehr wo der ist aber anscheinend ist er gar nicht auf mich gegangen sondern die andere jetzt ruckelts wieder
monka es warum
das ist teilweise total total random
vor allem mit obs auf habe ich irgendwie
Viel weniger fps aber war son ist grottig grottig programmiert ist jetzt ja teilweise wie die sachen nicht nachgeladen werden
Ja ja ist gut
Wie findest du die performance von war son auf dem pc nicht gut
nicht gut also für die optik und und überhaupt das game ist sehr
So halber arschbacke gemacht
Was darf sein storage wir können auch mal zur tv station
Aber macht suchst ja aus
Lass wir das doch schon sind wir sind wir schon die profis mittlerweile guck mal jetzt haben wir sogar eine kaufel direkt an storage tauschen
Besser geht es doch nicht
Tomika ich glaube das wird lange dauern
spielentwicklung ist ich spiele gerne aber spielentwicklung ist irgendwie nicht meins hat mich auch nur
hat mich auch null interessiert bisher
Der sound der anderen beiden müsste jetzt aber eigentlich besser passen als am anfang müsste jetzt deutlich einfacher zu hören sein
Oh du scheiße das ist das halbe flugzeug
Auf gut glück hier rein ok
Schiebte diese komische platte rein
Ja aber hier müssen viele sein die sind bestimmt auch schwimmbad getroppt
Der typ ist direkt hier vorne in dem storage tauschen stopping power jetzt kriegen sie auf den sack
Jetzt machen wir so platt den heißen berg
Sollen wir die direkt überraschen die gehen jetzt gerade rüber zur lagerhalle
Heißt nicht die lagerhalle ist so schlecht dahinten
Zum reinkampen zum reinkampen so ein bisschen das spielstil
Ja unbedingt wollen wir die pushen oder nicht
Da landet einer
Habt den gesitzt auf auf dem dach hier ist einer gelandet grad
Was
Aber einer müsst ihr sein oder ist er verreckt hast du ein poch
Das war wirklich schwierig hier grad so
Oh fuck dann lass weg kommt dann
Wo geht es nicht rein in das kackdinger das problem ist wenn wir das crossen wollen dann
Achtung sie eben schon auf uns mit zielfernrohr ja das ist ja lasst uns verpissen
Luten wir lieber noch ein paar sachen hier wenn noch was da ist kiste ist noch da
Gis da hier ist was für dich
Das ist so der lautscher fan
Ich sehe mich da schon
Braucht ihr noch platten
Jetzt habe ich meinen stopping power ausgetauscht big brain
Ok ok ok weg weg
Ich bin da noch drinnen
Einer down ich hätte abhauen sollen ich hätte abhauen sollen nicht
sehenlos rum nicht sehenlos rumsitzen einfach abhauen gleich gleiche sporn
Wie kommt der gestand so schnell dahin ach das war keine stand das war eine flash
Als ihr bleibt einfach nur im spawn stehen im gullag und es funktioniert
Oh nice, ihr habt genug money.
Ist knifflig gerade, weil da oben vielleicht ein Tod drin bei der Kaufstation.
Äh.
Eeeh.
Gleich hier.
Was ist denn mit dir?
Komm noch mit?
Ich laufe da.
Okay, genau.
STBA 42, Dankeschön.
Sieben Monate.
Huge IQ-Subscription.
Ah, die will, dass ich mein Loadout abhole.
Okay.
Danke.
Wollen wir zum Loadout-Drop oder wollen wir?
Okay.
Bei euch sind Waffen oder, dann loot ich jetzt schnell mal da, bevor wir da hingehen.
Was sind das?
Snipers.
Oh Wahnsinn, 13 Schuss, huge.
Für was?
M4.
Aber ich nehme jetzt eh gleich mal ein Overkill-Trop, wenn es gut ist, dann habe ich wieder.
Wenn man nur noch in Emojis redet.
Pog.
Pogu.
Ja, das sehe ich.
Genau, dann hole ich den Heal.
Hier hat jemand ein Profi-System?
Nee.
Nein.
Hier unten ist Free-Sniper.
Ah, ich habe eine tolle Drohne.
Dodge die Raketen mit der Drohne, ich muss die jetzt fangen.
Oh, ich wurde jetzt echt selten im Heli.
Kommt man hier überhaupt drauf?
Ah, so.
Jetzt.
Warte, warte, warte.
Da liegt noch ein Matzengeld.
Hier hinten liegt auch noch Zeug.
Please, go catch me.
Wo bist du?
Links.
Was ist der Plan so?
Vielleicht mache ich so einen Quarry mal.
Hoch und weit.
Hoch und weit, genau das auch.
Über den Waldhof.
Manchmal spawnen hier auch eine Kaufi, das ist komplett random irgendwie.
Ja.
Die ist da oben an diesem Monument.
Wir sollten gucken, dass wir vielleicht ein bisschen Kohle kriegen und ein paar UAVs und
Killstreaks kaufen können, weil...
Wo ist man hier?
Und Schuss und auf jeden Fall Munition brauchen wir noch.
Also ich...
Ich bin auf dem Weg.
Aber da wird vielleicht auch jemand kämpfen.
Ich sehe jetzt gerade nichts.
Okay.
Ich sehe da noch schon welche.
Wollen wir abspringen?
Okay.
Exzellent.
Also eine Runde Platten?
Ja, ich habe eine Runde Platten für dich, wenn du willst.
Okay, ich komme.
Danke.
Warte.
Ich habe noch genau 200.
Passend.
Ja, lass hochlaufen.
Das geht hier, glaube ich.
Kann ich mit dem Heli drunter kommen?
Nee, passt.
Komm, glaube ich.
Hier liegt noch eine.
Die kann ich hier aufnehmen.
Ja, ich habe auch 24.
So.
Ich habe vier.
Ja, das ist...
Von wo schießt?
Lass mal irgendwie eine ordentliche Puzzle suchen.
Heli?
Gut, dann.
Ich habe einen Profisystem auf dem Heli.
Wir brauchen unbedingt Munition.
Unbedingt Munition.
Wir sind doch echt gut hier.
Hier oben.
Bravo, bravo.
Dann sollen wir mal einen linken Profi sammeln.
Hast du ges...
Das ist ja gut.
Ja.
Wir müssen das zum Schutz sammeln einmal, dann gucken, wo wir hingehen.
Der Heli sollte eigentlich hier safe sein.
Geht dem Profi.
Ich habe 210 Schuss und ich habe alles voll.
Ja, ist gut.
Was brauchst du, Max?
Was brauchst du für Munition?
Assault Rifle.
Ich bin immer noch hier wie Sand am Meer.
Ja, ich habe auch nichts.
So, ist Orangen aus, vielleicht?
Ja.
Da war ich gerade.
Da war nichts drin, oder was?
Nee.
Okay, ich habe 5k.
Okay.
Wir könnten jetzt eigentlich auch noch so eine Taufe geben.
Oh, Leute, guck mal, guck mal.
Der hat mich gesehen und schon gedreht.
Falscher Mann, oder?
Ja, der hat mich gesehen und schon gedreht.
Der geht zu dem Drop.
Der looted deinen Drop da.
Ja, moin.
8000 Meter weg.
Nein.
Der weiß aber, dass er...
Der hat Angst.
Da unten rennen noch Leute über das Feld.
Oh, der hat Angst, der hat Angst.
Der hat Angst, der hat Angst.
Der hat Angst.
Ich snipe, HD.
Sein Team, Achtung, von links.
Das andere Team, das pusht ihn jetzt.
Das soll jetzt den puschen, komm.
Oh, ich habe ihn gedownet sogar, Null.
Wegen.
Ich habe ihn gedownet, den da.
Den Fallschmier, den da.
Da sind noch 3 Leute.
Keine Muni dafür.
Ich brauche eine Munibot, sondern...
Was?
Von wo?
Wo?
Das ist von mir.
Vor mir.
Hier, hier, hier.
Waark, ich seh ihn, warte.
Nice.
Hier, komm zu uns rechts.
Wo ist der Loot hingefallen?
Hier, hier
Wo hat er denn nicht?
Junge
Ich take mal deinen Cash
Du musst aber, wenn du mich kaufst, ich muss schnell sein
Ja, können wir das machen
Keine Ahnung von wo es snipet
Wo willst du?
Sag schnell, du kaufst mich oder nicht?
Ich hab zwei down
Huge, huge snipes
xxx des snipes hd
An der Mauer, oder?
Ich hab keine ammo mehr
Ich geh von hinten hin, ich geh von hinten hin
Ja, also einer lebt noch von denen
Ja, ich komm von hinten und ich geh von hinten hin
Eigentlich jeden, der lebt, da müssten zwei noch leben, der eine würde wahrscheinlich wiederbelebt
Der ist hier
Oben drauf, oder was?
Bei grün, bei grün
Guck mal der Drohne, wo die sind
Ich mach
Ich hab jetzt jetzt eins drin und stell es mich ran
Was in 100 Jahren spielt der?
Die sind richtig schlecht
Ich seh nicht, wo die sind
Auch nicht
War die unten drin, oder was?
Nee, oben drauf, der ist oben drauf gerannt
Ich bin grad oben drauf
Du müsstest diese Rottensäen irgendwo
Nö
Irgendwas beschießt mich, von der Straße aus
Von der Straße aus
Markier doch hier
Ich kann da grad nicht rausfasen
Die haben irgendwas dagegen
Ich bin von hinten
Alter
Sag, wenn du Engage, dann guck ich raus
100 Meter weg
Die sind weg
Ah, der pusht mich
Der eine pusht mich rechts
Quatsch
Oh, oh fuck
Der ist low, der hat Armour-Break
Nice
Ich wurde noch beschossen
Von der Seite, vom Berg, von rechts irgendwo hier oben
Da liegt noch eine rechte Waffe
Da liegt noch keine Muni
Die haben uns im Positoben
Weg, weg, weg, weg
Ich hab immer noch keine Muni, egal
Da liegt bitte noch Eier Muni
Da liegt noch Eier Muni
Habt ihr Raketen dabei?
Nein
Das ist nicht viel, aber es ist ehrlich zu arbeiten
Das ist eins
Wir sind aber richtig gut in der Zone hier
Ja, R4 ist gleich auf 10 hier
Hinten, R4
Die forschen drüber
Lass hochgehen
Der kommt auch hoch
Der andere ist hinter der Mauer
Einer rechts
Die haben einen gekauft
Ich seh grad nichts
Wir müssen an den hinter uns denken
Armour-Break
Einer KO, der ist KO
Da hinten läuft noch einer
An Blau
Von hinten, von hinten, von hinten
Der snipet mich an
Der ist ziemlich nah
Der ist da ungefähr wo das Out
Wo das Squad steht
Hier seht ihr ihn
Der ist auf mir drauf
Da ist glaube ich auch nur einer
Von hinten, von hinten
Auch einer
Wo ist der andere hier?
Von hinten kommt auch einer gegen
Überall, ich weiß es nicht
Was zum Teufel, was hält der aus?
Was hält der aus?
Was zum Teufel?
Ja, loote mich
Was für welche Hügel, Matthias?
Auf dem von uns
Der kann aber echt nicht mehr viel ausgehalten haben, der Typ
Da hat die viele Shots noch gebraucht, Blut
Bei dem Hügel oder was?
Bei Grün?
Das kann auch unten drin sein
Wir haben eine absolute Mülleimer-Pose hier
Das ändert auf dem R-Field, im O-Field, Alter
Oh mein Gott
Ich finde die gar nicht so schlecht gepostet
Ihr hättet gerade genug Kohle, falls irgendwo eine Kaufi hier ist
Da wäre eine
Zwischen uns noch ein Gegner
Egal, dass es so ein bisschen von hinten
Hier können wir auf dem Trubel, gell?
Ich glaube es ist zu riskig, aber...
Da rennt er
Nicht, nicht, nicht
Ich lasse ihn von innen holen
Jetzt, Leute, easy win, ich sag's euch
Die machen das, die zwei
Drei, Leute, direkt vor dem Ding
Kommen hier vielleicht rein
Einer
Einer rechts hinter uns
Einer hinter uns, Teddy
Du musst ihn holen
Der andere kommt, glaube ich, hinter
Der ist oben drauf
Bist du schon unten drin?
Ja, da bin ich schon unten drin
Hinter dem Holz
Wo kann ich hinten noch rausgehen?
Ach so
Wo ist der?
Kommt er nicht hoch?
Das ist ein Ekt-Spiel
Nein, nicht du
Wo bist du?
Der rett sich jetzt
Aber da ist noch irgendeiner close
Wesen zumindest
Das hat mich unübel low geschossen
Die crossen wir die Kacke jetzt hier?
Gar nicht
Easy crossen wir die gar nicht
Wir müssen, aber da war irgendeiner noch close
Egal, lass mal auf den nicht nüde rennen
Oh, hinter euch
Können wir machen, ja
Da vorne liegt ein Drop
Vielleicht fliege ich direkt zum Drop
Ja, sobald ich da bin
Also ich sehe gerade hier
Okay, ich gehe jetzt direkt zum Drop
Top, weg ist Snipe noch
Wir sind aufgeteilt
Wir sind absolut tot, Mods
Nein, wir sind nicht tot
Ihr macht das
Ich brauche eine Platte
Nein
Ich werde in der Luft geholt
Ja, das war es, Alter
Ey, er sniped mich in der Luft
Noch 11 Gegner, komm
Ah, okay
Ja, das war echt unlucky
Next
Der hat eben wieder so unglaublich
viel ausgehalten, der eine Gegner
Man, jeder 4000 Damage
und 60 kills oder sowas
Ja, mit Weltrekord Gamplay wird es nichts
Ja, aber dafür müssten wir ja auch
in eine gute Lobby kommen
Ja, vielleicht erst mal bei
Activation anrufen, ob wir nicht irgendwie
das Matchmaking kriegen
Also wenn das einer machen müsste, dann du
Ja, das interessiert auch keiner
Da musst du schon, wie heißt der
Witzter
Oder wer auch immer sein, dann ist kein Ding
Das geile ist
Es sind ja mittlerweile dadurch,
dass sie nicht bestätigen und nichts dagegen
sagen, was Killbase Matchmaking
und sowas angeht, sind so viele
Mythen und Gerüchte im Umlauf
Ja
Die schreiben in der Chat
Das zögert jeden
Im Shop
Ja
Kann man das in Game machen?
Nee, kann man nicht
Mal gucken, wie hart man aufschlagen kann
Das hört sich aber echt ungesund an
Mach mal, fliegen wir mal gegen die Lagerhalle
Aber gerade beim Aufschlagen
Chat, guck mal
Gerade beim Aufschlagen merkt man, dass der Server
total wenige Ticks hat
Der registriert das total spät, wenn man auf
Guck mal
Ach nee, okay, das ist die Zeit abgelaufen
Da ist man unverwundbar
Aber es ist so, du schlägst auf
Und es dauert irgendwie gefühlt mal so eine halbe Sekunde
Bis es dann auch zählt
Sehr, sehr merkwürdig
30 Ticks
For the win
Cineastische Experience
20 Ticks
Oh, sorry, sorry
Ach so
Ich darf nicht so nuscheln, sagt einer
Alles klar, nuschel ich
Nuschel
Storage Schaum
Das Flugzeug ist sogar ganz gut dafür
Bei 150 Spielern geht nicht mehr, doch
Nuschel
Da landet einer, direkt an gelb
Keine Waffe
Beschütze dich, einer kommt rechts neben uns
Ich brauch irgendwas
Einer direkt hier, direkt hier
Geh wieder zurück, da wo du herkommst
Wo ist der nächste?
Noch einer, noch einer
Wieder einer B
Der kommt da runter
Movement
Gutes
Ich hab ne K98, Alter
Zurück im Gulag
Ah, hier ist was Gutes
Der hat ne M4, hei
Hier ist noch einer
Sicher, dass du nicht mich gehört hast?
Nee, einer fehlt noch
Was haben wir denn hier für einen Auftrag?
Soll ich den Bounty annehmen?
Ah, ich dachte vielleicht kriegen wir den hier
Wow, wow, wow, wow
Hier in der Mitte irgendwo
Irgendwo bei mir
Okay, nice
Wie sie immer genau
Im richtigen Moment um die richtige Ecke gucken
Guck mal wo der sitzt
Hier drin
Da drin
Erstmal sagen wir das
Das ist der beste
Erstmal sein Zeug looten hier
Was sonst?
Hallo, Ecke, please
So, komm wir gehen in den Schwimmbad gucken
Dass wir da noch ein paar Platten kriegen
Da liegt noch ne Fall
Ich hab ne M4 und ne P90
Und wir haben richtig gut Geld
Jawoll
Das ganze Team ist ja auch eliminiert
So hier, kauf ihr am Start
Jawoll
Ich leg dir hin
Ja, und tausche direkt noch Platten
Der braucht keine Platten mehr
Gehen wir mal ohne Schwimmbad gucken
Jawoll
Ich seh die Herzen
Okay
Die Drohne hat auf jeden Fall
Braucht auf jeden Fall Geld wert
High impact
Da ist sie
Also ohne die Drohne wären wir schon lang tot
Ach doch, jetzt pushen wir
Wo ist denn da was?
Hier
Okay
Wir können zusammenlegen und uns noch ne AW holen
Ich krieg nen Shot
Durch die Wand
Irgendwo ist ja noch ne Kiste da
Wahrscheinlich oben drauf
Ich hab grad dieses Geräusch bekommen
Wenn ein Shot so 1cm an deinem Kopf vorbei fliegt
In dem Haus drin
Wollen wir uns noch ne AW kaufen?
Können wir machen eigentlich
Ich leg mal
Der hat schon 4, du kannst eine kaufen
Brauchst die einfach
Ich kauf dir auch eine hier
Soll ich sie gleich zünden?
Nee, nee
Die wär noch mehr wahrscheinlich als die da oben
Ich weiß nicht
Soll kurz schauen, wo gehen wir jetzt hin am besten?
Wollen wir da runter, wirklich mal runter pushen zu gelb?
Oder wollen wir hoch
Oder wollen wir hoch zum Airport
Weil wir pushen ansonsten da
Airport macht mehr Sinn
Ich hab den Rock Lounge dabei
Weil ich ihn nicht gescheitert für 2 Dorf gefunden hab
Ist wieder erstaunlich ruhig gerade
Viel zu ruhig
Man nutzt nicht mal einen Schuss
Ich kann dir versichern
Das ändert sich gleich
Ok, was ist die Quote auf deine Versicherung?
Auuuh
Bitsch primes ab
Da war doch schon der erste Schuss
Das ist schon gewonnen
Wollen wir noch ne AW kaufen?
Ja
Das ist schon gewonnen
Das war mir eigentlich klar
Man nutzt nicht mal einen Primes ab für dich
Wo?
Unter uns, oder?
Hat der oben in die Luft geschossen?
Oder ist der im Klo?
Wahrscheinlich
Wann hast du den jetzt organisiert?
Oder hast du kurz geschießt?
Ja, natürlich
Ich hab mit auf 2 Mischung gestrinktsnabbert
Im 2 PC hinter dir
Handy
Mobile
Das ist wirklich erstaunlich, Ruhig
Hier ist auch ne Ungelute
Der ganze Airforce
Wo soll ich sein?
Da ist ein komplettes Training gelandet
Das versteh ich nicht
Vielleicht hatten die ja spontan keinen Bock mehr auf dich
Die sind halt oben auf dem Dach gelandet
Die haben sich gedacht, lass uns für uns liegen
Ja man, das war ein Streamsniper
Lass halt die 2 hier machen
Hier oben z.B. ist gelootet, also hier sind Kisten auf und so
Hier nicht
Äh
Verarschne, jetzt haben die das wieder an Dist
Die haben so gelootet
Wie man nicht looten sollte
Du kommst nicht hinten in den Aufzweig
Da muss ich wieder halb den Parcours weg machen
Hier rum
Hier sehen wir noch ne Kiste
Hier rum kommst du
Heading this way
Wo ist das denn, Alter?
Oh
Hier rum kommt man hoch
Relocating
Was soll ich sehen?
Gasping closing, get to the new safe zone
Zeigst du mir?
Hey warte mal
Wo ist der denn?
Der ist im
In diesem Flugzeug Beladungsding, oder?
In diesem Tunnel zum Flugzeug
What the fuck
Wo?
Tower, tower, tower
Tower, tower
Mokas, wie sie alle sitzen wieder
Alle sitzen sie irgendwo
Ihr habt kurz Ruhe, einer ist gedauert
Der Tower hat kurz Beschäftigung mit aufheben
Moment, hier ist auch verkehrt, oder?
Ich hab noch 2 Raketen
Ich glaub ich sag kurz Hallo zu denen
Boah, hier ist richtig schön das Smokeband
Voll safe
Aber beim crossen jetzt halt nicht
Egal
Wir können ja durch den Airport noch bisschen
Es wird kurz brikant hier
Wo wollt ihr eigentlich hin?
Bei dem Auftrag, aber du kommst leider nur so rum hier rum
Mokas
Was war das?
Ich hab mal eine Rakete reingeschossen
Vom Choker
Oder was?
Der hoch
Ne, nicht ein Choker, ein
Ein RPG
Kommt man hier irgendwie rauf?
Ja, doch hier
Dann geh weg
Ich hab hier drauf geschossen und jetzt bin ich durchgerannt
Danach
Wie heißt es auf Englisch?
Ähm
Das ist gefährlich jetzt aber ein bisschen
Hier war schon jemand
War da mal irgendwer?
Die ist drin, aber egal
Ich mach die alleine halt Mokas
Ja
Ist bei euch gerade
Einen durch den Glas gesprungen?
Ah hier, Gegner
Den auslaufen zu mir
Du bist gut ein Freund
Alter, man kann hier nicht durchlaufen
Ich bleib einfach liegen, gar nicht sicher hier
Hast du irgendeine Idee wo?
Ne ne, aber da war ja richtig schlecht
Hä?
Was war dein Auftrag Kumpel?
Also ich seh absolut nichts mehr
Das könnte eine interessante Queryzone werden
Das warst du unten im Fenster, ne?
Jawoll
Wir können auch da hinfahren, gell?
Jo, können wir machen
Ich hab hier ein Auto, hat jemand einen Koffee?
Ne
Ich hab eins, ich hab eins
Ich komm zu dir
Ja
Aber ihr dürft nicht so lange hier unten rumstehen
Ja, ihr müsst hier auch noch so weit
Oh Gott
Meter rückwärts fahren
Was machst du denn?
Da bist du, Koffee
Sonst fährt sich aber ein Auto rein, wenn wir so weit fahren
Ich wollte so einen guten Move machen
Poggers Move
Oh Gott
Ja, nicht gegen den Baum
Ich hab grad auf die Map geguckt
Nach links vielleicht nicht, blaue Marker
Okay, dann mach ma
Dann mach ich
Das Ding ist aufgehalten
Brauchst du Platten?
Ne, ne
Ich dachte du hast ihn überfahren
Über die Brücke
Okay, gut
Was gibt es denn, als fertig ist?
Da wird auf jeden Fall auch gleich
Eine Rakete von oben kommen
Was haben wir?
Oh, Missile Locking
Ich vertraue
Warum bist du raus, Max?
Missile Locking nochmal
Weil ihr was von raus erzählt habt
Doch
Ich vertraue
Nicht picken
Die sind oben
Jetzt ist er weg
Dann lass wieder rein
Hinter uns ist noch ein Auto, das können wir nehmen
Die stehen oben auf dem Dach
Alle drei
Hätten durchfahren können
Echt
Atme ich ins Mikrofon, das ist keine Absicht
Wenn er auf und zu atmen
Natürlich
Die haben so extra Bock
Auf snipen da oben
Da muss man
Du bist jetzt hier so ein bisschen im Schatten vor dem Baum
Guck mal hin, die haben keine Ahnung
Ich glaube jetzt ist es besser
Wir könnten noch mal so einen der gerät machen
Da sind ja richtig viele
Lass den linken mal vielleicht
Der linke liegt außerhalb von einem Haus
Das ist schon ein Vorteil
Jawoll, aber dann bleibt das
Hier hockt 100 pro wieder irgendwas im Haus
Es sitzt immer was im Haus
Ahja, auf gehts
Aha
Ja, wir müssen mal was killen
Da ist niemand
Holy cow
Wenn mir das dreimal ganz laut zeigt
Wenn das funktioniert
Ach das ist da oben
Wir haben es markiert
Mit einem Leuchtsignal
Ich höre ein Auto
Ich glaube die sind gegenüber auf dem Haus stehen geblieben
Nicht auf dem Haus, aber gegenüber auf dem Berg stehen geblieben
Ja, da war ein Auto
Oh, die sind close
Close, close, close
Wo sind die
Close
Kommen wir mal Hardspeed sensor
Erstmal hier bisschen verteidigen
Ich seh nichts
Wo schießt wer
Random
Ich seh die da dran
Wo ist der
War der unten oder oben
Hier unten
Hinter dir nochmal
Hier noch drin
Hinter mir
Ich mach mal eine Tür zu
Alter, ich darf die Tür nicht zumachen
Wir machen das jetzt hier
Hier
Nein
Das waren die nicht
Ich hab rechts auf der Map eingesehen
Achtung, da kommt gleich wieder einer
Hier
Ich seh den hier immer noch im Leben
Das ist der eine gewesen
Du lootest hier so random immer irgendwelche Dinger
Nee, generell in dem Game loot man random immer irgendwelche Dinger
Gegenüber
Der läuft da so sehr spät, der Kopfstation
Der kommt da wieder her
Ich hab noch 12 Tage
Aber wir haben keine Kopfstation
Wir könnten da rüber
Macht ihr Türen auf und zu
Wo ist eigentlich meine Waffe hin jetzt
Bei der ganzen Geschichte
Weg
Ich hab noch ein ULV
Ich weiß nicht ob wir das jetzt schon machen sollten
Erstmal rausgehen
Tja
Das wäre echt praktisch
Das ist so dead, das werden wir nicht überleben
Wir haben so viel Kohle
Komm ich mach jetzt mein ULV raus
Und wir gucken mal was wir machen
Das hast du euch beantwortet oder
Alles klar wir sind mittendrin in der Zone
Wir müssen nicht schlafen
Alter
Die gehen alle
Da treffen sich gleich zwei Teams an der Kopfstation
Da gehen wir mit drauf und machen die Blatt
Die gehen zwei Teams an die Kopfstation
Es sind mehr als zwei Teams
Es sind drei drei und zwei
Wir müssen eigentlich alles
Wir können uns ja auch verkampen
Die sind in zwei Napo Häusern
Zwei in den beiden Häusern
Da kommt gleich ein Team dazu
Hier oben ist auch was
Ja ja rechts auf dem Berg sind auch welche
Wir sind aber mittendrin
Wir müssen eigentlich die Zone abwarten
Runde abcampen
Ich hab schon ein bisschen was gemacht
Ich hab nix zu tun ich T-Bag
Einfach ein bisschen auf der Stelle
Das ist High Octane Gameplay gerade
Oben bei grün
Aber die wissen das
Hier bei grün
Da kommt ein Lufttank so
Nee da rennt jetzt mega viel raus
Da hinten rennt auch noch einer raus am Haus
An gelb ist auch noch einer ins Haus gerannt
Man sieht so viel mit neutralen Grafiksettings
Der eine wurde wiederbelebt
Achtung auf rechts gucken
Der muss jetzt rennen
Einer down
Hier Achtung bei uns kommt gleich einer
Da stehen total viele unter uns
Unter uns
Hilf mir hilf schnell
Da ist noch einer
Und Platten rein schieben
Erstmal Platten rein
Was
Achtung Scheiße
Kannst du die ein bisschen nerven vorne
Oben drauf
An den Drop gehen wir
Ja
Ich guck oben
Doch doch doch doch
Okay
Ich seh es
Achtung
Achtung die sehen dich von da
Ich kann gerade nicht aufstehen
Richtung grün
Ich hab einen markiert
Die wollten es wieder wissen
Die haben bestimmt auch die ganze Runde auf dem Bash gesessen
Ich mach kurz Pause und geh Eis essen
Das ist quasi unsere Weltrekorde Runde
Achtung
Max am schwitzen stellt der Chat korrekterweise fest
Mans not hot
Ich bin gleich wieder da
Only easy
Ich mach kurz Pause
So halbe Stunde 45 Minuten
Wie viele Wins schon?
Mit mir dabei 3
Ich bin mal kurz weg
Ich sprühe mal weiter
Ich bin auch mal weg
Ich hause mal den W3
Ich bin mal kurz weg